this is the last photo
so i guess that uh hasselblad 150
million dollar
investment it's starting to work hey
guys it's angelica max and vadim
and today we are doing another blind
camera comparison
with the oneplus 9 pro the iphone 12 pro
max and the s21 ultra
i went out and i took a bunch of images
i have 30 of them
lined up over here vadim and angelica
have not seen
these images so we're going to be taking
a look and they're going to be choosing
which one they think looks best without
knowing
uh which brand shot at which phone
anything like that so go ahead and get
out a piece of paper
or maybe your notes app we want you guys
to vote along with us it's a ton of
fun uh because oftentimes we're
surprised
so let's go ahead and take a look at the
first image right here we have a nice
bright day
i think i like the one in the center it
looks the most sharp and i like the
white balance the best too
the the street looks a little bit warmer
and i think the detail on the bricks
is also good i think the right one looks
the most detailed to me
yeah i don't think anybody can guess
which one of these images
is from which phone i don't even
remember let's do it okay
so here's the one plus nine and which
one did you choose the twelve promise
max all right next image here we have a
portrait
shot yeah the center that's true that's
s21
why is the iphone so blurry that's crazy
come on apple
all right and here we have an ultra wide
and i gotta say i'm excited for the
oneplus 9 pro because it has a 50
megapixel ultrawide and i've always
been unhappy with ultra ride photos as
far as sharpness so what do you think
well
i think i'm seeing more detail better
image overall
on the left i agree i agree
12 pro max in 12 megapixels right there
12. all right and we have a portrait
shot
of the sign i was beginning to like the
one on the left because kind of like
this bokeh down here looks kind of nice
but i noticed that there's a big chunk
right here
that is not getting blurred where here
you can see a little bit of blur on the
outside and kind of the roll-off looks
more natural with the background
all right let's take a look oh all right
12 pro max and here is a standard shot
outside no fancy effects but
one of these photos is taken with a 108
megapixel sensor
another with a 48 and then one with a
12.
to me i think it's between the left and
the right in terms of detail i think the
one in the center either lacks contrast
or lacks detail
and i think the one on the right is too
cool in terms of the white balance
so i think i'm going with the left i
like it overall the best uh
to me i think the one on the right has
more detail
and i don't mind the cooler white
balance i think it makes
it look a lot prettier okay
that's right bam interesting looking at
you guys results don't tell them
anything yet
but all right and we have our first
selfie
which shot do i look the best in center
center okay the center first i can't say
anything yet no biases for me
no i like it okay the detail on your
face the center one looks
definitely the best all right let's go
bam
okay 12 pro max what did it do this 20
s21 looks
killer all right so this is an ultra
wide shot indoors
cool coffee shop bakery thing can you
guys tell the difference
as far as detail at all i mean you guys
still choose what you like the best
because two of these are 12 megapixel
one is a
cool sounding 50. the one on the right
if you look at these
signs i think the text is the most
detailed and clear
but on top of that if you look at these
lights it's the least blown out
because you actually see the texture in
detail where these two are just
literally just globes this one's the
worst
yeah 12 pro max how does it do
what's it doing oh is it uh what's it
called what's that feature
deficient deep fusion that must be deep
this is stacking multiple images okay
now we have a macro shot over here
okay so i will say i'll add this in
not all of these smartphones are able to
get as close
as the other ones some can get closer
than others but i wanted to match these
up
so it's still fair if you're taking a
macro shot you want to get close to your
subject
this is the best you can get with each
phone for me it's got to be the center
because you have all that texture in the
skin look at that crazy detail
and the uh the gem the crystal whatever
stands out like crazy what would make
you pay more
for this necklace what if this was the
overages
exactly you can can't really see much on
the others
so the center it looks really nice and
12 pro max so these are the original
images this is how close
you can get and apple actually has made
some updates recently
with how they're doing things so that
was actually pretty surprising looks
good
and we have some macarons right i like
the one on the right and the back
everything else gets a little more
blurry i'm pretty sure
vadim might pick the center one but i i
really like how this looks
no i'm also going with the one on the
right for the same reason the the
depth of field you have this all sharp
and focus and over here you have some
nice
blur yeah it kind of gets your attention
over here instead of having that image
with the
stuff really good one plus nine finally
all right we have a portrait shot
outside this was a very difficult
situation obviously it's very harsh
lighting i'm going with the right for a
couple of different reasons first off
the highlight roll-off on her skin very
natural
and in terms of the jacket the detail
looks really good especially if you look
down
to the jeans where you see the jean
texture so right
i definitely like the right one as well
the only thing i don't like about it is
sadly yeah
the edge blurring on the hair got messed
up it's really sad everything else i
really like
iphone not bad all right and here we are
shooting
into the sun i mean this one kills it
with the glare like there's no glare
that is impressive yeah you still see
sky
you still see contrast this one's
probably the worst
but obviously that's good
one plus nine it's really okay
and we have a shot of the flag
shot of the flag and the one on the
right
kills it kills it much more detailed oh
yeah instantly
all right s21 ultra
and we have a portrait shot that is
backlit
i think i like the one on the right the
most even though
it's kind of like washed out in warmth
from the glare or whatever but the all
the others have glare
too and i don't know it kind of has an
almost
dslr feeling to me i like it more than
the others
i was really gonna go with the one on
the right for the same reasons
as angelica had but there is that just a
little bit of flaring there and it's
kind of like less contrasty so
i think i'm gonna go with the center
even though it's not perfect
it looks to be like the most clean in
terms of
not being as flat due to flaring in
detail too
one plus nine to me there's a lot more
to me even though there's flaring
there's a lot more detail like in their
faces
than the others and it just looks more
definitely a lot of differences like
color wise
brightness of the faces white balance a
lot of differences here
all right and we have some buildings
here to me
i think i see more detail on the one on
the right yeah the one on the right is
definitely more detailed that is the s21
ultra
so like i mentioned you can shoot 108
megapixels which is a mind-blowing
number
compared to 48 compared to 12 so it was
clear that
with the iphone you definitely are
missing out on detail if you care for a
shot like this
then we have another one here yep by far
the one in the center
destroys the others once again the one
plus
well not once again i guess it lost last
time so this is ultra white as you guys
could see
50 megapixels is that a gimmick well i
guess it's not if we are getting more
detail
there outside compared to the other two
all right and we have a portrait shot
here
uh just after sunset i think i'm
definitely gonna go with the one
in the center it looks the most natural
to me and i'm seeing more
detail i'm going with the one on the
right the middle
one looks a bit too flat in my opinion
all right 12 pro max is average
and we have the androids got the points
there
all right and then we have these little
guys in coeur d'alene
so this is also a portrait shot a wider
portrait shot
i like the one in the center the most
there's a lot more contrast and a lot
more blurring with the portrait which
makes it
a lot sharper and easier to see i'm also
going with
the center it did a killer job with the
blur edging especially
with it having more shallow depth of
field can i add in it's interesting how
the antler
is like a little bit blurred out here
not as much of the background
and this is in focus so it has nice
depth whereas this is all in focus here
so so this looks more natural really
good yeah more realistic one plus
nine man so i guess that uh hasselblad
150 150 million dollar
investment deal thing they did it's
starting to work
it's pretty good all right so we have uh
basically sunset time we have a selfie
here
i just look mad yeah i don't know if
you're very happy
i think i definitely like the one on the
right the most
i gotta say i don't know what you're
gonna say but that looks pretty dang
good
yeah i definitely have to go with the
right yeah the detail is crazy on the
facial hair
pores is it like blurred out here like
it's not even focused i don't even know
what happened here
so much contrast like the edges on your
hair everything and what about all this
noise
oh yeah i also don't remember which one
is which i mean i think this might be a
samsung because i remember it was great
at
selfies but yep s21
and what happened with the oneplus just
was there
i was looking at their advertisements
and they were like ignoring the selfie
camera they kept focusing on the back
here is there a reason for that maybe
all right and we have a shot over here
oh definitely the center banner destroys
them wow that looks good
center so good yep s21
kills it really good detail and then
sun is basically down here i like the
one in the center
the most at first i thought the right
just because the white balance
everything looked natural but you can
tweak it in post
and there's so much more detail with the
center and if you look at like the
tassels and everything the others get
like
motion blurred or whatever but
everything in the center is kind of
perfect
yep i'm also going with the center
detail is
much better than the other two and here
on the left you can kind of see some
blown out detail
in the tassels too so i think the center
12 pro max good all right and we're
into nighttime photos this is the ultra
wide here it's got to be the center yep
i mean that detail is
killer very good detail and it looks
like it actually
um less blown out lights way less blown
out you can tell
so it's doing everything great one plus
nine plus that's good very good that
ultra wide lens is killer on there
yeah apple needs that all right and
this is a standard lens night mode as
well do you notice anything about this
i do i know which one's the iphone it's
this one um
it has a crazy reflection issue yeah
that's super annoying
so that just looks really bad does that
mean you're going with the right it says
no reflections at all i have an idea of
what of which one this is
i don't remember from putting these
together but you see this has a little
bit of reflection
but it's blurred out this is flat and
horrible looking
this has none like how do they pull that
off yeah it's definitely got to be the
right it looks so clean
one plus this looks like closer to a
dslr shot
these look like cell phone images right
here all right we have a nighttime
tower shot here i mean even though the
one on the right is all just
very dark i'm still gonna go with it i
think i see much more detail especially
if you look inside
of the building uh where they where the
yellow is there's so much
noise and artifacting that's 20 s21
this is a portrait shot at night
it was very dark here very it doesn't
look like it was very dark
all right i'm gonna go with the right
here the one in the center i think is
too flat
and i like the how the bokeh looks on
the lights in the background
i like how everything's brought up a
little bit all right
s21 ultra and we have this crazy scene
there's lots of lights
lots of darks lots of colors this is
really tough but i'm gonna have to go
with the right just because the other
two i don't know if it's
artifacting or something but they just
look really weird and unnatural
yep i'm also going with the right it
looks incredibly clean
very clean the contrast is there the
colors pop and there is some
kind of artifacting noise in the sky
whereas this one's incredibly clean and
it still looks like nighttime
where this kind of looks like it's
trying to become day this has some color
but
very impressive i agree 12 pro max
that was surprising very good and we
have an ultra wide shot here
and the lights actually weren't changing
at all so this is their white balance
and how they are
thinking okay definitely the right okay
so you're going for the right
honestly i'm gonna go with the left
mainly because the sky
is like pitch black whereas the other
two are kind of gray
so i really like that extra level of
contrast from the sky being just
see i i don't i don't like that a lot
everything over here
is crushed because of that even though
this is brought up and it's not as
dark everything is so sharp and clean
everything's a good point that's a good
point
12 pro max and one plus nine wow i gotta
say i think
so far that's pretty good that ultra
wide yeah
in all in all ways is just killing it
that is pretty good got a portrait shot
here
whoa which one's the worst the center
the center
yeah i think in the center her skin is
just underexposed
the left the left one's pretty pretty
bad too there's like not as much detail
everything's kind of like flat and what
about detail in jeans
like you look over here
i'm gonna go with the right even though
like i wish the sky was a little bit
more
dark but that level of detail and the
exposure
and detail of the face and skin is just
yeah it's very good to me the main
subject
yeah that is way more and i guess like
you can't
get detail if it's not there but you can
always add some contrast if you want to
right
s21 ultra very good an iphone
and um thankfully emily wanted to take a
photo of me
and it actually turned out pretty good
definitely the one on the right the
other two are blurry
no detail really on your face yep i'm
also going with the right because
um the colors kind of stand out his skin
color is
kind of separate from like the lights
color whereas these two
this is very pink all of it and this is
also very kind of pink purplish whereas
that kind of has
it looks natural yeah the sky is very
dark but you can still see
like the contrast so basically much
better and
pretty much every way 12 pro max
oh that's crazy okay
all right we have this is i thought this
was just crazy tough
with night mode super dark super bright
all these colors all right so this one
is pretty difficult
but i am going to go with the left
because the other two kind of take on
the same general kind of flat color
like across everything buildings
everything but this one has like
depth you know yeah i don't know depth
or like the
this looks very clean i think i'm
actually gonna go with the
right it seems like less blown out you
can see a lot more detail on the inside
i really don't like how the sky looks
everything looks kind of flat and bad
but i'm thinking maybe afterwards in
post you can edit it add some more
contrast add something to it
all right and let's see what it is
oneplus one plus nine and
this yeah whoa what else this is the
last photo
uh the phones happen i don't know very
dark
and i made sure that's not a fluke i
actually took three photos with each one
and i chose uh the best one from each
three just for this situation because
it's so dark and you have to hold it
steady
this is really really tough but i think
i'm gonna go with the one on the left
i'm gonna go with the one on the right
so the middle just
everybody wants to choose the middle one
the middle's terrible and i feel like
the one on the left is just
has a little bit too much contrast and
it's a little bit too dark
it almost feels like there's two
floating heads whereas on the right make
some good points
everything kind of like you still see
the detail in the jackets
so you kind of see what's going on i
kind of like the contrast and dimension
because the right one
looks pretty flat i feel like you get a
little bit more detail even though it's
darker
both look pretty pretty good and close
compared all right
one plus nine and i have to look it up
after this but no it does not have
uh night mode for the front-facing
camera wow it just doesn't happen
really i know we dealt with that with
the iphone 11 oh
and now sometimes but i guess oneplus is
still behind
in that way so there we have it guys
that is the
end so go ahead and pause this video
count up
what your scores were make sure to
comment down below because we want to
hear your guys's opinion
to see how you scored because opinions
are different as you guys could see
i have been trying not to look at you
guys's sheets
since it's been a while so make sure you
comment down below
and let's see let's have angelica go
first what did you get
i was tied between the s21 ultra and
iphone 12 pro max so the new oneplus
hasselblad
fancy camera system is in third place
for you
all right but these two are close all
right and vadim what did you get
my scores were very close to hers i got
nine
for the oneplus 9 pro 10 for the iphone
and 11 for the s21 ultra very so almost
the same
just a couple off that is really
surprising just one off
so overall do we have a a new king or no
let's see well you get tied you saw
that's the new king i mean it's just
very good good inside it does
scenarios and we try to make it i try to
make it balance with a lot of different
scenarios
obviously the s21 is killer for the zoom
if you care about zoom like every time
was dna that's
probably what made it win this thing was
killer for the ultra wide
it yeah it was awesome on those and the
iphone i think
all around well balanced very well
balanced all around you could say that
so
thank you guys for watching um if you
guys want to see
our little side-by-side comparison
between these two full comparison we
have it right over there
we'll also be doing a gaming video so
click that little circle above to
subscribe
and we will see you guys in the next
[Music]
video
[Music]